This video is sponsored by war thunder,
play war thunder for free and get a premium aircraft tank or ship.
And a three day account's upgrade as a bonus available on PC PS4 and
Xbox one more on them.
Yes.
American politics is rarely a setting for controversial heroes, Washington,
Jefferson Lincoln Roosevelt's public opinion has settled and congealed around
these men. Offering Rosie soliloquy is of their patriotic fortitude.
This echo throughout the generations,
the American institution rarely examines the complex reality of its
historical figures.
That's simply not possible with today's protagonist modern day Macchia Valley,
whose quick rise and fall to power forces us to weigh his intense
against his methods.
He was a smooth talking Louisiana and who considered himself a righteous every
man, both before and after he took complete control over his state's political
machine.
He threatened assassinations installed puppet governors and ruthlessly
taxed enemy factions, but it was all for the greater good of his people.
Is there a room in a Republic for autocratic benevolence? Well,
you be the judge while we examine the life and times of human.
[Inaudible].
Long was born on August the 30th, 1893 in Winfield,
Louisiana long's family was quite large.
His mother Caledonia to son and father Huey senior conceived nine living
children here. He was the seventh at the turn of the century.
Much of Louisiana was poor and uneducated, but even by local standards,
Winfield was a tough place to make a living. The long family was far from rich,
but they were well off relative to their surrounding community. Here.
His senior Aaron's Caledonia made a living as livestock farmers and lived in a
small Southern Manor house. The lungs rarely had much trouble making ends meet,
but plenty of people around them did, which was a major influence on young Huey.
One story recounts South as an eight year old boy,
he watched his neighbor lose his house and farm at auction.
When the neighbor failed to pay his debts on time,
the farmer begged to be given his home back swearing. This had pay his dad's.
If he just did a few more days to get the money together just as the sheriff was
about to stop the auction and grants,
the neighbors request accredits and made a bid winning the farm as an adult Huey
long recalled the events remarketing that he was horrified.
I could not understand. He said it seemed criminal.
Winfield helps mold Huey long in more ways than one.
It wasn't just the object poverty around him.
It was also the unfiltered contempt that many of the Northern Louisianans felt
for their richer Southern neighbors. As I said,
Louisiana has never really been a wealthy state,
but much of the money that it does have is concentrated in large population hubs
like Baton Rouge and new Orleans, many people from Queens pole,
North Louisiana towns,
like Winfield's often resented the upper class that primarily resided
closer to the coast, take the civil war as an example,
like most of its Southern neighbors,
Louisiana seceded from the union and fought as part of the Confederacy and the
American civil war.
When state representatives gathered for a vote on secession delegates from
Winfield, voted to remain in the union,
not because of any forward thinking positions on slavery or States' rights,
but as the Winfield delegate petits who wants to fight to keep the Negroes for
the wealthy planters. It wasn't a civil rights argument. That's all.
It was class war out in the late 19th century,
Winfield and the surrounding area became a local hub of populist politics.
In 1912, the local parish actually supported the socialist party,
presidential candidates, Eugene Debs over all other candidates.
It was not a place that trusted corporate priorities or power structures.
Those who did have jobs worked in blue collar industries, local lumber, mills,
and salt mines,
Huey lungs worldview was highly influenced by his childhood in Winfield.
He was a curious child exploring the farm and the world around him,
asking questions and listening to political philosophy from a young age,
public schooling was sporadic in rural parts of Louisiana at the turn of the
century.
So here he was homeschooled until adolescence as was common for any boys.
At the time when he finally did reach public school,
he was initially praised as gifted with an uncommonly good memory.
He routinely asked teachers to allow him to skip coursework or even in Tonya
grades when he was already familiar with the material at Winfield high here we
began. So it really uses intelligence on the debate team. At one point,
he traveled to Baton Rouge and finished that in a statewide debate contest,
running himself, an academic scholarship to attend LSU after high school.
Unfortunately he would never be able to cash in on the winnings.
He couldn't afford the textbooks or the room and bought QE would return to
Winfield with his only remaining prize,
being all that increased female attention that skilled high school debate club
winners are accustomed to hear he soldiered on throughout his remaining course
about graduating from Winfield high school in 1910 after completing the 11th
grade, or at least that's what he thought.
Just to see we long finished the 11th grade.
Since we're set to receive his diploma,
the state board of education passed a new laws saying that the 12th grade would
be the new ending point for high school students QE the skilled debater as he
was thought that the new law was a crock of crayfish and deep again,
circulating a formal petition,
denouncing the idea of 12th grade and formally criticizing the principal and
teachers at Winfield hype. Ultimately here, he got his wish.
He never had to complete the 12th grade because the school expelled him as a
result. He never graduated from high school,
High school education officially over.
He knew he needed to find a job like a lot of biographics protagonists,
Mr. Long was a multitalented man who could adequately perform quite a few tasks.
He would sign up for just about any job that didn't involve farm work.
He wasn't keen on chores around the house as a child.
And he wasn't about to sign up for any more of it as an adult long wanted to be
out in the world around people and things.
He never wanted to end up back at home, surrounded by chickens and goats.
So at the age of 17 long became a traveling salesman touring much of the
American South and selling everything from cooking Sherry to home medicines,
it was a job. He had quite a bit of natural talent for,
and as Sanchi found success right out of school for a solid year,
but as the economy stalls and sales became harder,
long was forced out of his budding young sales career and forced to consider a
new line of work.
His mother who had always hoped her seventh son would use his God-given
intellect and communication skills in a more righteous calling,
pushed him to move to Oklahoma so that he might move in with his older brother,
George and studied the Bible in the fall of 1911.
He began attending seminary lectures at Oklahoma Baptist college in Shawnee.
Well, attending lectures is a rather loose way of putting it long,
quickly deduce that he was no man of the cloth and began skipping classes.
The washed out of seminary school after one semester,
much the chagrin of his devout Baptist mother. But before he left Oklahoma,
he thought he might want to give law school. A try.
George lends him a hundred dollars and pointed him towards the university of
Oklahoma school of law,
where he similarly lasted one semester received average grades,
and didn't learn very much thanks to a slew of distractions ranging from girls
to gambling. They enjoy the local political scene in Norman,
where the university of Oklahoma is,
but he never focused enough on law while he was in towns,
really get serious about a career in litigation.
He lost his a hundred dollars and a gambling ring, leaving towns.
He returned to a promising sales position.
This has opened up for him long was still a teenager when he left Oklahoma,
but he had a real mind for sales. He learned early on that dressing.
Well then just salesman credibility.
And the playing music could help him draw a crowd and to foster a commercially
appealing atmosphere,
he tapped into his natural powers of empathy to connect with potential clients.
As a traveling salesman who encountered working class people all over the
American South,
he quickly developed a sense of fellowship with everyday Americans.
There was another relationship that Huey long was quickly developing to a
blooming romance with a woman named Rose McConnell long and McConnell mass in
1910,
early in his sales career at a bake sale that had been organized in Shreveport
to promote the sale of a lawn substitute called Carter lean.
QE had a little bit of games.
So he awarded the top two prizes to Rose and her mother,
they married two and a half years later on April the 12th, 1913,
the Gayoso hotel and Memphis Tennessee zones have three children named Rose
Russell and Palmer sales remains a good career choice for long,
but it also continued to prove inconsistent and fickle in 1914, the economy,
again,
through Huey and Rose out of the industry and back toward formal schooling.
But this time he had a much clearer plan. His oldest brother, Julius,
who was already a working attorney,
helped him create a streamlined law school outline,
specifically targeting and course material that he would need.
To know in order to pass the Bob Cuban.
Rose moved to new Orleans and just three semesters. Later in 1915 here,
we had cobbled together enough knowledge and information that he was able to
pass the bar exam. He was 21 at the time long returned to Winfield.
When he now had the legal tools,
he needed to grind his acts against the corporate interests that had grown to
low over the course of his young life.
They began building his reputation as a lawyer by representing poor powerless or
disenfranchised Louisianans.
He opens a law office in the space above the Winfield bank,
which was run by his uncle George.
He promptly sent waves through both the community and design family by
representing a widow in court against the very bank.
He shared a building with his uncle was incredulous that young Huey had taken
the cases. It appeared to represent a conflict of interest here.
He remarked that his uncle should feel complimented human long.
Don't take out off the top waters,
but after the big fish gage and massive Olson,
that person speech aside long was gifted liar.
It quickly gains notoriety in Northern Louisiana as an attorney who wasn't
afraid of targeting powerful groups,
making them popular among many of the local populists in 1918.
After three years in Winfield,
he then Rose moved to Shreveport where they had more clients and more resources
at their disposal.
He also began one of his life's biggest conflicts is ongoing standoff with John
D Rockefeller's standard all company around the time that long moved to
Shreveport.
He also invested about a thousand dollars into a local well that eventually
struck oil long was set to make a major profit off the investment,
but Rockefeller standard oil,
wasn't interested in buying the oil from this particular well,
making it theoretically valuable,
but practically useless long had made a sizable investment and gambled
correctly.
Yet he still lost his money because of the whims of standard oil is righteous
anger alongside as established animosity towards power.
And corporations touched off an ongoing feuds that he would continue to stoke
for the remainder of his life.
He called standard oil and invisible empire that was run by Petra new mites.
He made his first formal shot across the bow in 1921.
When he began representing a small oil company who had a disputed lease with
standard oil long lost this court case, which only fueled his hatred more,
but there was one interest for Huey long that captured his attention much more
than legal battles and oil Wells.
What began as a natural curiosity for politics thrown into a full fledged career
interest and long was new longer contended to attack the power structure as a
private citizen. He wanted to do it as an elected official. Now,
just before we continue with the video today,
I do want to take a quick moment to thank our sponsor.
Thunder war thunder is a realistic free to play military vehicle combat game.
It's available on PCPs for an X-Box one, but you only need one of those,
no need to purchase it either.
You just download the game and you get to playing in this game.
There are over 1,500 historically accurate vehicles all the way from the 1920s
to the 1990s, they're all carefully built,
incredibly detailed and all the physics you can tell that it's really been
sweated over plus the sound's really immersive. And look,
you can just jump in for a quick games, arcade game.
It's useful if you don't have a lot of time or you can play realistic and go
over some more challenging stuff, or if hardcore, you can go for simulator, but,
uh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, if you're new,
you're probably just going to get your whipped over and over again.
So maybe start in arcade and go for that.
So join us on the battlefield for free using the link below, doing that,
support this show, and you also get a free premium tank ship or aircraft,
and three days of premium time as a bonus, just for registering.
Let's get back to the video.
[Inaudible].
Huey long officially became a politician.
When he ends elections of the state railroad commission in 1918,
at the age of 25,
he used his position on the three men board to limit corporate monopolies and
reduce utility rates. For average households,
he believed he was the sort of populist.
Every man that 20th century American politics should rely upon just as long
had quickly gains local acclaim as a populous minded attorney.
He similarly gained statewide notoriety for the Halle raised from his elected
position.
The state railroad commission was eventually rechristened as the broader public
service commission and long became its chairman. In 1922.
His first act was to Sue the Cumberland telephone company for raising their
rates by 20% for no particular reason, his first attempt to lost,
but he argued his appeal before the U S Supreme court.
And one Cumberland was forced to cut refund checks,
totaling $440,000.
This was distributed to 80,000 customers who had been overcharged subsequently
chief justice, William Howard Taft,
to describe as long as the most brilliant lawyer who ever practiced before the
United States Supreme court,
the Cumberland's case one long thousands of statewide fans. As I long,
decided to run for governor in 1924, as he had done in his entire life.
He mocked the ruling political establishment in new Orleans,
labeling them as toothless pawns of malevolent companies like standard oil.
Ultimately he finished third in the race,
missing the runoff by about 7,000 votes, long blames, the poor weather,
which wasn't an entirely unfair observation on his part with only 200 and some
miles of paved roads in all of Louisiana at the time,
heavy downpours transforms dirt roads into intractable. Muddy messes.
Given that the core of long's base was the rural populist contingent.
The weather almost certainly impacted his showing to some degree,
but the weather wouldn't be a problem.
Four years later when long successfully took the man's all from acting governor
RML Simpson by 1928 long had carefully constructed a massive populist Alliance
in Louisiana.
He spent a four years trips in across the isolated Northern perishes building
his coalition by a dozen blue collar workers at a time.
He also improved his reputation in the more gilded Southern parts of the state
by supporting Roman Catholic candidates in an area dominated by traditional
Spanish and French heritage.
He tied everything together with a slogan he adopted from 19th century populist,
William Jennings, Bryan, every man, a King,
but no one wears a crown long won the democratic primary election on January the
17th, 1928.
Just like the fact that it was a heated three way election long one by what was
at the time, the largest margin in state history predictably.
When songs you cruise in the general election winning more than 95% of the
vote over a Republican candidate at young plat at 34 years old,
Huey long became the youngest governor in the history of Louisiana.
A record that still holds to this day.
Long as the sentence to the governorship was a radical departure of state
politics. Since Louisiana had become a state 116 years prior,
it had more or less been governed by the same corrupt members of the good old
boys network in Louisiana, all of whom had clear ties to the church,
the upper-class or powerful corporate interests long's election undid all of
that. Giving the average Louisiana a much more accessible ally.
And the governors mentioned, okay,
most Louisiana residents needed that ally in the late 1920s.
Louisiana was arguably the poorest state in the U S with grossly underfunded,
public works and public education systems.
Those who could afford to navigate their children to and from school every day
still had to purchase their own textbooks among other supplies,
making regular old primary schools, a huge burden for most families.
25% of adults could not read massive bridge tolls,
limited people's ability to move around in their own communities and poll taxes,
disenfranchised, poor people of all racial backgrounds and keep in mind.
These were the good times. This was in 1928,
just months before the start of the great depression.
Everything was about to get a whole lot worse, long has solutions,
do many of these problems,
but his methodology is what catapulted him to national fame almost immediately.
He fired hundreds of old guard bureaucrats,
replacing them with friends and young populous to he believed would serve his
vision of what Louisiana politics could be after consolidating his executive
power and installing yes men every way he could.
It began an ambitious 1929 legislative session designed at pushing through
a number of bills that he had promised in his campaign,
focusing on economic stimulus and improve state infrastructure.
He lowered one bridge toll from $8 and 40 cents to 60 cents.
He instituted his night courses for adult literacy that taught more than a
hundred thousand people to read. By the end of his term,
he levied a new tax on standard oil that paid for all textbooks for grade
school, children long was to the enacting large scale wealth distribution,
a political prospects that rarely succeeds on American soil,
but Louisiana was so fundamentally broken by a hundred years of corruption.
The most everyday people didn't seem to mind.
That's not say that everyone was on board, however long, strong man methods.
Well meaning, but they were also democratically dangerous.
And it didn't take long for an organism.
This political movement to rise up against it. In 1929,
while long was drawing to Navy a new occupational license tax against his
friends at the standard oil company.
His project was met with cries of foul play opponents in the legislature called
for an impeachment on the grounds of abuse of power among several other charges.
And the impeachment was sustained with a 67 to 13 vote. When something,
the prolonged camp discerns,
the electric voting machine used for the impeachment vote may have been tampered
with. And all our brawl broke out on the floor of the state house,
which was locally christened as bloody Monday and reached its crescendo when
Hugh his brother, Earl Bissell legislature on the neck,
no word on whether or not along with secret vampire right this year,
and this will be covered in a future season of true detective regarding the
ongoing political charges.
Huey continued to speak directly to the people of Louisiana,
where he knew that he could best plead his case there's money.
He was trying to earmark was for them, the people,
and it was a good cause social programs that would help lift Louisiana out of
the icy grips of poverty. Ultimately,
the state house passed seven articles of impeachment to the Senate,
which immediately declared it's intense to acquit long. If the charges,
regardless of whether or not he was guilty in their eyes,
the impeachment should have never gone forward in the first place until they
were treating us with the lack of seriousness that they thought it deserved in
all likelihood. Long's 1929. Impeachment was organized in backrooms by oil,
tycoons and wealthy Titans of industry who wanted to rid themselves of the
long nightmare before any more damage could be done.
There were no lessons there for Hubie long about politics or democracy,
only power. He doubled down on his authoritarian strategies,
committing to violence, intimidation,
and ruthless political operation to accomplish his populist goals.
I used to try to get things done by saying, please, he read and told the press.
Now I dynamite and out of my path.
[Inaudible].
Over the remainder of his term. Huey long, effectively transformed his status.
As governor into that of a local dictator, the ends will justify the means.
He told people he continued replacing appointed officials all around city and
state governments with populists that he felt were loyal supporters,
whom he could trust.
He also began a political ties that he called his war chest.
Anyone who received a job from Huey was forced to give up a portion of their
salary for a private funds that long kept locked away for either campaign needs
or personal projects.
Also surrounded himself with armed body guards at all times,
impar for show and in part, because he had begun to receive death threats.
It's an understandable reaction,
but when you look like a strong man and walk around like a strong man,
you start to act a little bit like one, two at one point it's a drunken long.
Allegedly told one of his bodyguards to kill a state representative. Jay,
why send his junior,
leave him in a ditch where nobody will know where or how he got there long,
still had lofty populist goals, but it also become an obvious autocrat.
He was hell bent on amassing as much political power as possible.
In 1930 with half his given national term still remaining.
He decided to run for us Senate selling his campaign as a referendum on his
political ideology. If you liked what he was doing for Louisiana,
he asked that you also vote for him for Congress. If not, he would resign.
The governorship long was running against a 72 year old incumbent.
Senator Joseph ran cell of the constitutional league long routinely mocked as
opponent declaring him may of the constipation league Q long,
eventually won in a landslide in September of 1930, earning 57% of the vote,
but long stayed in Louisiana. Fearful. Do you see the power here to mass,
to as Lieutenant governor,
by assuming his new congressional position in Washington,
he presided over hellish state legislature sessions by screaming at those who
disagreed with them, ordering them to sit down and shut up one night long,
steam rolled 40 bills through the state house and under two hours,
he had so thoroughly stacked to the state bureaucracy in his favor that no one
could effectively speak against him.
It was in these final dictatorial days as governor where long finally,
and his infamous nickname ability school supporter dubbed him the King fish
after a smooth talking character from a popular fictional radio program called
and Andy, the name immediately stocked beloved by friends and foes alike,
including long itself, long fended office,
slow moving coup in 1931 when his own Lieutenant governor Paul Sayre announced
that he did not believe long could be Senator and governor at the same time,
Sarah declared himself to be the brightful governor of Louisiana,
which regardless of whether he was right or wrong about the legality of longs
dual statuses was a pretty stupid plan.
Long had the national guard surrounds the state Capitol,
and then I'd see her removed from the office by arguing to the state Supreme
court that CEO had resigned his duly elected position.
When he attempted to assume the governorship with Sierra gone long installed a
puppet Alvin Alin King,
who temporarily assumed the governorship as long left for Washington in 1932
curious long-term puppet.
Oscar Allen won the full job in the given national election of 1932,
as long as settled into a senatorial duties,
still completely in command of Louisiana state politics as long pivoted to
national politics.
He supported fellow progressive Franklin Delano Roosevelt during the election of
1932,
believing he was the only candidate with policies that could shepherd the U S
through the depression.
But after FTL one office long actually became a major critic of the new deal
attacking Roosevelt's flagship legislative package from the left.
He believed that FDR and his depression era policies were not doing enough to
redistribute wealth in America.
Roosevelt's intern labeled Huey long as a radical demagogue long spent his time
in the Senate,
advocating for free college tuition and seeding the ground for similar
grassroots movements across America.
That helped him rise to power in his own state. In February, 1934,
he launched a radical initiative called the share our wealth campaign.
This might still be the most radical left of center idea ever seriously,
floated by a major American politician long wanted to cap personal annual
incomes at a million dollars and cap personal fortunes at $50 million,
the resulting tax income,
which helped build a guaranteed household income for every American family along
took care to remind Americans that 65% of the country's wealth was controlled by
2% of the population.
This plan would aggressively attempt to smooth those numbers out,
offering every family a month, paid vacation, old age pension,
and guaranteed that your long work week among other benefits, it was to be sure,
but radical plan, even by new deal standards.
When the U S Senate refused to seriously consider his proposal,
he started a private society. The share our wealth society,
which attracted more than 7 million members by 1935,
unfortunately Huey long would not live long enough to reap the political
benefits of his ideas. He published his first book, every man,
a King in 1933 and had begun writing a second tome called my first days in the
white house that made it pretty clear, whereas personal ambitions late,
but on September the eighth,
1935 long made his way to the Capitol building to vote on house.
Bill number one,
a rezoning plan whose met a goal was to ask the judge named Benjamin Henry Pavey
that long considered a political opponent long.
And his allies passed the bill Blake that night after 9:00 PM,
shortly afterward,
Patty's son-in-law called wise approach long and shot him one time.
And the chest Weis died almost instantly after long,
his body guards shot him more than 60 times long himself died at the hospital.
More than 24 hours later after doctors were unable to successfully repair the
internal damage to his body.
There are conflicting reports over what his last words were,
but one theory reports that they may have been, God don't let me die.
I have so much to do.
He was 42 long remains a controversial figure in American history because of the
lengths he went to to consolidate power and advance the populous legislation.
There is little doubt that he is a beloved figure in Louisiana,
more than 200,000 people attended his funeral and his body was buried on the
grounds of a new state Capitol building,
which she directly helped fund with one of his tax initiatives.
But outside of Louisiana on a national level long is often remembered for his
authoritarians strategies and his radical economic initiatives,
rather than a statewide benevolence.
He took money by force and used it to improve the lives of blue collar
Americans.
And he scoffed the checks and balances that are designed to constrain political
power.
Huey long remains one of the ultimate American raw shack tasks for Machiavellian
principles as long ones noses. The ends can justify the means,
but that's an awfully dangerous mindset when your sworn enemies have pistols.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos,
just like this a couple of times a week. Also,
please do check out our fantastic sponsor war thunder Lincoln.
Thank you for watching.